VOLLEYS, THE TEAM HAS STOPPED
BECAUSE THEY BARELY HAVE ENOUGH
PLAYERS TO PLAY EVERY NIGHT,
SCOURING THE G LEAGUE AND G
LEAGUE SHOWCASE.
>> Wally: UNPRECEDENTED TIMES.
CASSIUS STANLEY WITH THE BUCKET.
>> Mike: STANLEY PLAYED WITH THE
PACERS LAST YEAR, STARTED WITH
DETROIT BUT RE-SIGNED AGAIN.
SIX GUYS FROM THE G LEAGUE IN
THE LAST SIX DAYS.
QUICKLEY TRYING TO DRAW SOME
CONTACT.
SO HE WILL HEAD RIGHT BACK TO
THE LINE.
SIRVYDIS PICKS UP HIS FIRST.
>> Wally: OH, I LOVE THAT!
>> Mike: WHAT WAS -- THAT
REMINDS ME A COUPLE YEARS AGO,
REGGIE BULLOCK, ONE NUMBER ON
THE FRONT AND DIFFERENT NUMBER
ON THE BACK.
>> Wally: THAT'S RIGHT.
A LOT GOING ON IN THE KNICK
LOCKER ROOM.
EVERYONE TRYING TO STAY SAFE AND
STAY HEALTHY.
THAT'S FUNNY.
>> Mike: YOU LOOK AND THIS WAS
THE SAME THING LAST YEAR, THE
MEDICAL STAFF, TRAINING STAFF,
EQUIPMENT STAFF, BECAUSE SO MUCH
IS GOING ON ON A DAILY BASIS IN
TERMS OF ADDITIONAL
RESPONSIBILITIES, IN MANY CASES
THEY'RE OVERWHELMED WITH THE
AMOUNT OF EXTRA STUFF THEY HAVE
TO DO.
>> Wally: OH, YEAH.
AND ALSO, QUICKLEY'S OFF TO A
GOOD START.
I WOULDN'T CHANGE THAT JERSEY.
IF SOMEONE NOTICES, KEEP THAT
THING ON.
GOOD LUCK.
>> Mike: YOU GUYS ARE ALL SO
SUPERSTITIOUS, PROFESSIONAL
ATHLETES.
>> Wally: I GUARANTEE YOU,